now there's been no shortage of big
moments
in scottish politics in the last few
months but the announcement of a new
political party by alex salmond this
week
was still a huge development the
electoral system in scotland means that
the pro-independence
alba party might not damage the snp on
paper
but of course the independence movement
appears as divided as
ever now this weekend nicola sturgeon
has said there are serious questions
about alex salmon's behaviour towards
women in the past
which she says raises real questions
about the appropriateness of any return
to public office
well yesterday the former justice
secretary uh kenny mccaskill became the
most senior person yet
to quit the snp to join alba he joins us
now thank you very much for being
with us mr mccaskill now you of course
support scottish independence
but then six weeks before these critical
scottish elections you quit the snp
why do you think the snp is no longer
the party to deliver independence
well this is about adding to the snp
this is about delivering the independent
super majority
we are not contesting the lists of the
constituency seats that will be for
individuals to decide and certainly i'll
be voting snp
uh where i live but we're contesting the
list seat and in 2016
over a million people voted snp on the
list
and only four list msps were returned
for the snp
an opinion poll just yesterday indicated
that none would be returned
so what we're doing by asking people to
vote alba on the list
is to deliver that independent super
majority so that on the 6th of may
when its election is counted the
scottish parliament will stand against
boris johnson
it will be scottish democracy having
supported independence overwhelmingly i
hope
that will be juxtaposed with boris
johnson saying that scotland's just got
to do what he says
and that's unacceptable come on this
isn't about boris johnson is it
you might say of course i understand
fully that the list system means that in
many ways
it might appear to benefit the
independence movement on paper but what
you're doing is making this election
all about cat fighting in the
independence movement
nicola sturgeon versus alex salmond i
think some people might say well hang on
how can you say that you're trying to
help the s p
by quitting no this is about delivering
that independent super majority
i'll be 63 next month sophie throughout
my life
scotland has rejected the tories not
just boris johnson but thatcher heath
and others before
and continually were left with the tory
government we now stand with our economy
threatened by brexit
with our health service threatened by
trade deals upcoming nuclear weapons
escalating that are based on the clyde
that's simply unacceptable the time has
come for scotland to decide its own
destiny
you think the snp alone can't defeat
boris johnson and cannot
deliver independence that's that's
arithmetic's clear in 2016 the snp did
not get a majority
they had one million list votes and
returned four msps
the independent super majority could be
delivered by the alba party
on list the yes movement the
independence movement is a broad church
it encompasses
more than one political party and it
encompasses many people
in other or no political parties so we
believe that the time has come for that
independence movement to come together
reflected by more than one political
party but to make sure that there's a
scottish people who prevail and it's the
scottish people who decide
and that will be the scottish parliament
that will then confront boris johnson
after the 6th of may so this is all
about helping the snp
i'm a bit baffled by their reaction to
it all to be honest um after you
defected in blackford said
of you he's been an increasing
embarrassment to many in the snp
and his departure is somewhat of a
relief doesn't sound like you're leaving
the best of terms
well snp speak for themselves i've made
it clear that i'll be supporting a
former colleague in east lothian it's be
up to individuals in alberta to decide
what they do
uh but the yes movement the independence
movement is a broad church
it's not simply the snp the snp
on their own it failed to achieve a
majority in 2016.
alba party can ensure that there is an
independence
majority in 2021 we won't be beholden to
the snp because we are
not the snp but we certainly start
campaign for independence and we
certainly stand on the radical tradition
of the radical policies
that the snp used to and i believe in
many instances still support
used to stand on it's a bit of a slip of
the tongue there
no well there are issues that i think
have caused many people concerning the
snp
that's why some have come over just
today we had the uh
equalities officer from the snp coming
over
along with a colleague the other party
now has more mps
in scotland than the labour party we are
here to stay
we are going to deliver a result in 2021
in the mention
to make sure that it's in the super
majority that is delivered
this election is already becoming about
independence
we've got to make sure that the outcome
is about an independent majority within
the scottish parliament
and that allows scotland's democracy to
choose we cannot go on under boris
johnson
we've had austerity inflicted it's going
to increase
the time has come for scotland to go its
own way and to do so
would require to be an independent
nation i'm just trying to work out why
you think
alex salmond is the man to help deliver
the independence that you want because
according to the latest opinion poll for
sky news
nicholas sturgeon's got a plus 21
approval rating among scots
plus 2067 among independent supporters
alex salmond's approval rating is minus
60
and even 68 of yes supporters have an
unfavorable view of him i mean do you
really think he's an
asset to the independence course well i
think alex almond was pivotal to the
independence cause and delivered the
2014
referendum but this is not it and he
wasn't
and that's why others have come on board
just yesterday we had corey wilson a
former
snp mp joined the party just today we
have councillor lynn anderson
the equalities officer for the snp they
put their trust and faith in mr salmond
and exactly the same as a scottish jury
acquitted him on all charges
a jury that was overwhelmingly
represented by women
uh you say very rightly of course that
he was
acquitted by that jury nicholas scotland
nicholas sturgeon says though in a
scotland on sunday interview today that
serious questions have been raised
about the appropriateness of his
behavior towards women while he held the
highest office in the land
i think that raises real questions about
the appropriateness of any return to
public office
do you think that alex salmon still has
serious questions to answer as nicholas
sturgeon says
no we've had two court cases he has been
successful in both a civil and indeed a
criminal court action
that is behind us we go forward and
indeed it's from this
sturgeon to our school but why others in
the snp who behaved inappropriately were
not dealt with
but we're going to keep this positive on
independence we're not here to battle
with the snp we are here to win
on the list and that will be contesting
against the snp because they can't
deliver
that independence super majority but we
are part of the wider independence
movement it is not the prerogative
of one political party there is more
than one political party pursuing
independence in scotland
and i will continue to campaign for
independence target my fire against the
unionist parties who are once again
seeking to coalesce
and i would hope that other political
parties would recognize that it's a
common cause of independence
not name throwing that they should be
carrying out now of course
as you say you know alexander's always
denied all of the harassment allegations
made against him
he was cleared of all the charges in
court important state
but in the court case his defense lawyer
did say i'm not here to suggest he
always behaved well or he couldn't have
been a better man on occasions
because he certainly could have been
better and alex almond has previously
said you know i'm no saint
i've got flaws are you comfortable
being in a party with him as leader well
let him without sin cast the first stone
since we're
speaking on a sunday equally you're just
asking a tory minister about behavior
within the tories
i think the people i'm most concerned
about it would be allowing boris johnson
to continue
running the roost in scotland along with
the likes of pretty patel or matt
hancock
so when it comes to this i think the snp
the alba party
and indeed the politicians in scotland
most parties stand far above that
so i'm comfortable and as i say that was
shown by corey wilson
and indeed lynn anderson today showing
that they have every faith in him
but this is about the alba party
delivering
that independence super majority it's
not about any individual
and it's not about name throwing or
tittle title and i hope that people in
my former party will reflect
upon who's actually shown commitment in
the past
and who's still showing commitment in
the future and that we should show some
common cause
rather than as i say seek to divide the
independence movement
just finally at the last election you of
course stood under the snp
banner you're now representing a
different party
shouldn't you hold a by-election
no i'll be doing what has been done
before at the outset of the scottish
parliament donald jr and labour mps
exercised the dual mandate
during the parliament that i served in
alex hammond and indeed john swinney the
deputy first minister of the scottish
parliament
uh stood on a dual mandate and
represented both westminster and
holyrood
so i'll be seeking to represent
hollywood as well as retaining and
continue to serve my constituents in
east london
okay thank you very much for being on
the program kenny mccaskill there
thank you